we begin with details on a fire at the
resorts world property just days before
its grand opening
people from all around the valley saw
the heavy smoke in the air
earlier this evening madison kimbrough
joins us live near the strip with the
latest on the situation
madison yeah sasha said this caused
quite the stir this afternoon as
visitors and locals saw big plumes of
smoke coming from resorts world
now take a look at a video that was
tweeted out by jake gallon
he tweeted this out this evening where
he really saw the extent of what was
going on
although clark county fire department
has yet to confirm any further details
this is what we know so far the fire
broke out behind the parking garage
off of sammy davis junior drive it
started in a storage construction area
with
building materials and other mechanical
equipment inside
luckily it did not spread to any other
structures but the cause
of how the flames erupted is still
unknown 38 personnel responded to the
scene
and the fire was quickly extinguished
here's what onlookers had to say about
what they saw
we saw the fire on the building and
there was smoke and it took us around
the
building or around the strip it's scary
because it's a new hotel
so like there shouldn't be having these
problems
looked like something had been burning
for quite some time we just heard a lot
of smoke from our room but we assumed
that it was from the construction going
on
it was real cloudy